the lionesses came for the trophy they  got the trophy and partied light  champion  but it wasn't just about winning a  tournament it was about inspiring their  young fans to want to play and changing  how women's football and sport is viewed  in this country  they showed grit and determination in  their individual stories and how they  played but the joy that came with it was  infectious  it's not about the money for this team  they each earned a win bonus of 55 000  pounds just a little more than the  winner of love island and most will go  back to their wsl clubs on teacher level  wages  but the platform is set for so much more  they have big social media followings  they've become household names  they've shown the demand is there to  watch them play in bigger stadiums  these history makers have won the hearts  of a generation and changed women's  football forever  jackie baltrow sky news  [Music]